ya no hay vuelta atrás donald trump
afrontará su segundo juicio político a
partir de la semana del 8 de febrero ya
fuera de la casa blanca' acusado de
incitar el ataque que tuvo lugar en el
capitolio el 6 de enero
chuck schumer líder de la mayoría
demócrata en el senado ha dado a conocer
todos los detalles de un proceso con el
que pretenden pasar página
insisto todos queremos dejar este
horrible capítulo de la historia de
nuestra nación en el pasado pero la
sanación y la unidad sólo pueden existir
si hay verdad y rendición de cuentas y
eso es lo que este juicio proveerá is
what de straw by el próximo lunes 25 los
líderes de la cámara de representantes-
leerán los artículos del impeachment
mientras el martes serán escogidos los
senadores que actuarán como fiscales en
este juicio a partir de este momento las
partes involucradas tendrán hasta el día
del inicio del proceso para presentar
sus defensas legales son necesarios 67
votos a favor de los 100 miembros del
senado para que trump sea condenado y
ahora mismo la cámara alta está dividida
a partes iguales entre ambas formaciones
con el voto
de desempate en manos de la
vicepresidenta harris aunque los
republicanos tienen una responsabilidad
doble en este proceso el futuro en el
trump está en las manos de los
republicanos son los republicanos los
que tienen que decidir si quieren que el
futuro del partido siga siendo dirigido
por la figura del trump así que se
encuentra el partido en una situación
donde pueden condenar y liquidar al
trump de cualquier futuro político
tuvieran que tener un segundo voto si es
condenado un segundo modo que con la
mayoría de uno se daría en falta 51
votos en el senado le prohibiría el
presidente de ocupar un cargo federal en
el futuro
de ser hallado culpable se convertiría
en el primer presidente de eeuu en ser
condenado tras un juicio político
[Música]